AND DANA PERINNO.
WITH THE FIVE.
AND KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE.
SEE ROSEANNE DISAPPEARED FASTER
THAN A CLASSIFIED E-MAIL ON
A SERVER.
ABC SAW THE HANDWRITING AND ONE
STOP LIQUIDATION WHILE YOU WAIT.
I AM KIND OF SAD, BUT I AM
SHOCKED.
NOT FOR ROSEANNE, I AM SAD THAT
THE EXPERIMENT FAILED.
WHY DID IT INTRIGUE US?
THE SHOW WAS A MESS.
IT WAS NOT BECAUSE WE LOVED
ROSEANNE, WE KNEW SHE WAS NUTTY.
BUT MAYBE IT SIGNALLED PROGRESS
WHERE THE PROS AND CONS CAN
BREAK BREAD.
BUT NOT ANYMORE AND THE WORLD
MOVES ON TO WHO EVER IS NEXT.
>> WE KNOW WHAT DONALD TRUMP
THINKS.
WE KNOW WHAT ROSEANNE BARR
IT IS RACIST.
THEY ARE EXHIBITING RACIST
BEHAVIOR.
>> IT WAS A GREAT MOVE
YESTERDAY.
THE THING THAT IS THE BACKGROUND
OF ALL OF THIS, THE PRESIDENT
CAN BE RACIST AND NOTHING
HAPPENS TO HIM.
>> ROSEANNE'S SHOW WAS CANCELLED
BECAUSE SHE TWEETED OUT RACIST
STUFF.
>> I BLAME DONALD TRUMP.
>> TENS OF MILL COMBRONS OF
PEOPLE VOTED FOR HIM.
>> ARE THEY RACIST?
ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP IS RACIST?
>> YES, YES.
>> THE DISCOURSE IS OVER AND THE
LEFT TAKES THE IDIOTIC WORD FZ
ONE PERSON AND BLAMES IT ON
MILLIONS.
IT IS ABOUT THE LEFT EXPANDING
THE TWEETS TO THE PRESIDENT AND
BY CONNECTION HALF OF AMERICA
WHICH RAISES A INTERESTING
QUESTION.
DID PRESIDENT OBAMA OWN
ROSEANNE'S BELIEF.
SHE BELIEVED THAT THE BOSTON
MARATHON WAS STAGED.
WAS THAT ON OBAMA WHEN SHE WAS
A HARD-CORE LEFTIST?
NO, THAT IS ABSURD.
BUT THE CURRENT MRAFRNGET OF
BLAME SUGGEST IT IS ALWAYS BEEN
THERE REGARDLESS WAS ROSEANNE.
IF IT WAS NOT HER, IT WOULD BE
SOMEONE ELSE.
THE LEFT DOESN'T NEED ROSEANNE
TO SMEAR YOU.
THEY ARE AT WAR ALREADY.
SHE'S BACK ON TWEETING AND YEAH,
YEAH.
I DON'T THINK SHE WILL GO
QUIETLY.
>> Dana: BUT SHE SAID I AM SORRY
I OFFENDED.
I AM OFF TWITTER AND THEN GOOD
BYE.
IT IS LIKE PEOPLE ARE OBSESSED
WITH TWITTER AND SELF WORTH IS
IN TWITTER.
>> Greg: ONE OF HER LATEST
TWEETS.
I WAS NOT A RACIST AND ONE
STUPID JOKE IN THE LIFETIME FOR
FIGHTING FOR CIVIL RIGHTS AND IT
WEALTH WILL NEVER BE TAKEN FROM
ME.
SHE WAS A SOCIALIST.
>> Jesse: LEFT, AND RIGHT AND
THE OTHER.
GERALDO:  YOU MAY NOT COMPARE
A BLACK WOMEN TO CANAPE.
END OF DISCUSSION AND YOU GET
FIRED AND YOU NUANCING IT AND
BLAME THE PRESIDENT.
YOU TAKE AWAY THE
RESPONSIBILITY.
I AM GET OF DRUNK TWEETING.
BUT THE THING ABOUT DRUNK
TWEETING OR TOWELLING IT REVEALS
YOUR SOUL.
I BELIEVE THAT DRUNKS ARE TRUE.
>> Greg: YOU ARE
A EXHIBITIONIST.
>> BUT THERE ARE SOME THINGS,
A LINE YOU MAY NOT PASS OR SAY
WHAT SHE SAID AND WHAT DISTURBS
ME DEEPLY IS THAT I SHUTTER TO
THINK THAT THIS IS WHAT INFORMS
HER COMEDY AND HER POLITICS AND
I THINK ALL OF US HAVE TO
EXAMINE OUR OWN SOUL AND SAY
CRAP, BACK IN MY DAY, 1950S AND
IN LOCKER ROOMS YOU SAID A LOT
OF STUFF INTOLERABLE AND NO ROOM
FOR WIGGLING AND NO ROOM TO
NUANCE AND IT WAS A KILLING
MISTAKE SHE MADE AND I HOPE IT
WAS A MISTAKE AND DOESN'T REVEAL
HER TRUE SOUL.
DPREG GREG THIS IS SARAH SANDERS
TALKING ABOUT THE DOUBLE
STANDARD.
SHALL WE PLAY THAT.
>> THE PRESIDENT POINTED TO THE
MEDIA SAYING THE HORRIBLE THINGS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND NO ONE
ADDRESSES IT.
WHERE WAS BOB'S APOLOGY TO THE
PRESIDENT WHEN JAMAL CALLING
HIM.
AND CATHY GRIFFEN ON A PROFANE
RANT ON THE VIEW AFTER
A PHOTOSHOWED HER HOLDING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DECAPITATED
AND WHERE WAS THE APOLOGY FOR
SPEN SPIN HIRING KEITH OBER MAN
AS HE PORTRAYED THE PRESIDENT AS
A NAZI AND THIS IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
SPEAKING B. THAT THEY ARE
INAPPROPRIATE AND THAT'S THE
POINT HE WAS MAKING.
>> Jesse: I LOVE THE DOUBLE
STANDARD GAME.
IT IS MY GO TO.
WHAT ABOUT--ISMS?
YOU CAN SAY BILL MARR SAID THE
WORD AND KEPT HIS JOB AND THEY
LIE ABOUT IT.
AND WE ALL KNOW REPUBLICANS HAVE
A SHORT LEASH WHEN IT COMES TO
THE MISTAKE.
DEMOCRATS WILL CIRCLE THE WAGON
AND GO FOR THE REPUBLICANS SCAL.
THAT'S THE REALITY OF IT.
GOING BACK TO ROSEANNE, THERE IS
A GREAT SCENE FROM THE OFFICE.
MICHAEL SCOTT SAID TO DWIGHT.
WHAT WAS THE MOST INSPIRING
THING I SAID TO YOU.
DON'T BE IDIOT.
WHEN I AM ABOUT TO DO TO DO
SOMETHING.
WOULD AN IDIOT DO THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT ROSEANNE SHOULD I
HAVE DONE.
SHE'S SELF DESTRUCTIVE AND
PEOPLE DO IT FOR DRUGS AND
PRESSURE OR RISK TAKERS.
CHARLIE SHEEN BLEW OFF HIS
ENTIRE CAREER OVER NOTHING.
WE HAVE SEEN PEOPLE PLANT TIME
BOMBS AND THE ME, TOO, MOVEMENT
FINDS THEM AND IT IS A SAD CASE.
IT IS IT SAD FOR NOT ONLY HER,
NOT REALLY HER BUT THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THE SHOW.
AND WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT THE
DOUBLE STANDARD.
CHARLIE SHEEN, LIBERAL.
AND ALEC BALDWIN LIBBAL AND
CATHY GRIFFIN LOST HER JOB AT
CNN.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE DOUBLE
STANDARD ARGUMENT HOMEDS.
WHAT ABOUT THE MONTAGE OF PEOPLE
TAKING HER TWEET AND SAYING ALL
OF AMERICA IS RACIST.
>> Kimberly: THAT IS A LIBERAL
PLAYBOOK.
THEY TETHER IT TO THE PRESIDENT
AND TRY TO CREATE THIS
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN ANYBODY WHO
MIGHT HAVE SUPPORTED THE
PRESIDENT AND ANYTHING BAD THAT
IS SAID.
I AGREE WITH PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND SHE HAS TO
TAKE OWNERSHIP.
AND CAN'T BLAME EVERYTHING ON
AMBIENN.
THAT'S THE NEXT TOPIC AND IN
THIS INSTANCE.
THE FALLOUT IS FAR REACHING IN
TERMS OF THE PEOPLE AFFECTED BY
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT AND SAID
STAY OFF TWITTER AND LACKING
IMPULSE CONTROL SHE WENT BACK ON
TODAY.
IT MUDDIED THE WATERS AND RIGHT
ON CUE.
MUDDY WATER.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS MY NICKNAME
IN COLLEGE.
MUDDY WATERS.
>> Kimberly: INTERESTING.
>> Greg: WILL NOT TELL YOU MY
NAME.
>> Kimberly: ROSEANNE SHOULD
QUIET DOWN AND YOU KNOW --
DPREG GREG I WANT TO BRING UP
THE AMBIENN DISANCE.
>> THE PRESIDENT MISSED AN
OPPORTUNITY.
HERE IT WOULD BE SO EASY.
YOU NEED MORE BLACK PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY JUST
A PASSING PHRASE.
HE COULD SAY EVERYTHING HE SAID
AND START IT WITH THIS IS
ABHORRENT AND I DON'T CONDONE
THIS AND AS MUCH AS I LIKE HER
COMEDY, IT WAS NOT FUNNY AND IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN EASY FOR HIM TO
REACH OUT AND TO DENY THE
NAYSAYERS.
>> Greg: SHE BLAMED AMBIEN.
THEY RESPONDED.
ALL PHARMACEUTICALS HAVE
SIDE-EFFECTS BUT RACISM IS NOT
A SIDE EFFECT.
THERE ARE POTENTIAL PROBLEMS
WITH AMBIEN AND ELECTRONICS.
>> Dana: I NEVER HAD A PROBLEM.
I DON'T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
I HAVE A HARD TIME SLEEPING AND
I WOULD TAKE A HALF OF ONE.
YOU HAVE TO READ THE
SIDE-EFFECTS AND FOLLOW THE
ORDERS OF YOUR DOCTOR AND YOU
CAN DO STUPID OR FUNNY THINGS.
>> Greg: I ATE MAYO OR PEANUT
BUTTER.
>> Dana: THERE WAS A NEW YORK
AMBIEN ATE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT DOUBLE STUFFED OREOS.
BUT IT DOESN'T MAKE YOU
A RACIST?
>> Kimberly: THE TINNING THAT
BOTHERS ME.
SHE SAID I WOULD APOLOGIZE YOU
DIDN'T GET MY JOKE AND NOW
SAYING I DIDN'T NEED TO
APOLOGIZE AND I TOOK ALCOHOL AND
AMBIEN AND MIXED THEM TOGETHER.
DPREG GREG I KNOW GERALDO, YOU
WILL REMEMBER THIS.
THIS IS NOT COMBUCHLT JIMMY THE
GREEK AND HOWARD COSLE AND WHAT
HE SAID ABOUT ALVIN GARRETT.
BUT IT HAPPENS LIKE ONCE EVERY
THREE YEARS PEOPLE SCREW UP.
>> THE A STUFF AND LIKE THE N-
WORD.
IT IS SO BLATANT AND RAW AND SO
DISGUSTINGLY ANTIQUATED AND AT
SOME POINT WHERE THE HELL IS
YOUR HEAD THAT YOU CONJURE THAT?
WHERE DID THAT SENTENCE COME
FROM?
TO PRETEND THIS OR THAT AND SORT
OF THE SAME OR THEY SHOULD HAVE
DONE THIS OR THAT?
THAT MISSES IT IS POINT.
>> Kimberly: THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA TO SAY IT WAS A LINK TO
THE PRESIDENT AND HE'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT MAKES NO
SENSE AND CHEAPENS THE DIALOGUE
AND WHAT SHOULD BE THE FOCUS ON
INTOLERABLE RACISM.
>> Greg: THEY BLAME IT ON TRUMP.
>> Jesse: BERNIE SANDERS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SHOOTER THAT
SHOT STEVE SCALISE.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK ANYONE
SAID THAT.
>> Dana: IT WAS NOT ME.
ONE OF THE PRESIDENT COULD HAVE
OWNED THE MEDIA WAS TO TWEET
SOMETHING ELSE OTHER THAN A
GREFIANCE FOR HIMSELF.